so you get a Disney Princess song in
this movie is it laying the dream come
true is it the version of the song you
always wanted to have 100% no joke yeah
yeah I yeah got to work with Alan Menken
who is you know has written so many
iconic Disney Princess but also wrote my
favorite musical Little Shop of Horrors
you know and like just getting to work
with him and yeah it was insane just
recording with an entire Orchestra like
felt very old-timey I've only seen it in
like old-timey movies that's amazing
you think Jon's little jealous that he
didn't get his so jealous yeah is he
reminding you all the time about like I
wish it was me here's a moment at the
end yeah he is actually a an incredible
singer he's me phenomenal that's so good
so we're talking about Ralph's
relationship and vanellope his
relationship together and how it's you
know how its evolving and how its sort
of changing it really reflects what a
lot of people go through now do you
think back on your old BFFs when you
were a kid and ever like try to use the
internet to find them look how to use
the internet or have they use the
internet to get back in touch with you
yeah yes I I I love doing deep dives
looking for kids I went to school yeah
I'm connecting with them it's amazing
when you're like just spending time
browsing internet what kind of videos
are the ones that like take up your
whole day unlikely an animal friendships
unlikely animal friendships yeah okay
I mean it's my favorite thing it gives
me like hope hmm they say the first rule
of the Internet and yes says it in this
movie is to never read the comments but
you're very good at engaging with people
online how do you like how do you keep
your composure when you're talking to
somebody who has like an opposing view
that you have um you know it I'm not
always perfect it's a it's a practice
you know but I
I disagree with people I love all the
time so it doesn't seem so odd to
disagree with people on the internet
yeah but just on big issues that's kind
of I'd it is a little mind-blowing
sometimes yeah but important to engage
in that conversation sometimes I can't
engage yeah but um you know I do the the
best they can with what I've been given
if you were gonna choose any of the
Disney Princesses that you that
vanellope gets to hang out with in this
film to actually hang out with in real
life like we're gonna go out on a
full-day date here in LA we're gonna go
get some food and get some drinks who's
it gonna be
geez Louise maybe I go like maybe Mulan
okay yeah or a or a the girl from brave
because because you couldn't understand
what she was saying like what that's
awesome thank you so much thank you
who's great really loved it oh thank you